tolle aschenbecher auf der lebensmittel
theke ist nicht in ordnung und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja ich
hoffe natürlich geht es gut mir geht es
auch ganz gut heute soweit müssten das
jetzt um die eigentlich müsste der
perfekt sein und sagen das sagt heute
der letzte part von das schlechteste
oder das beste restaurant war der
schlechteste mcdonald's habe ich
vorbeigeschaut getestet wenn ihr das
noch nicht gesehen habe zeigt dass auf
jeden fall nach diesem video ab auf
jeden fall habe ich dort in die
kommentare geschrieben oder auch im
video dazu aufgefordert leute schreibt
mir doch mal bitte was möchtet ihr als
nächstes was soll ich ab checkt also
halt welche art lokal das halt am
schlechtesten bewertet ist oder
eventuell doch am besten und ich habe
wirklich sehr sehr auf bäckerei gelesen
habe ich mal nachgeschaut ob das möglich
ist ob man da irgendwie bäckerei findet
die schlecht bewertet ist weil ich meine
warum sollte eine bäckerei schlecht
bewertet sein und ich habe wirklich erst
keine gefunden
bis ich dann allerdings irgendwann auf
diese hier gestoßen wenn das ist auch
die einzige die so eine schlechte
bewertung hat also die hat 1,3 sterne
was wirklich mit abstand am
schlechtesten war und ja wir haben jetzt
so nachmittags ich habe mir gedacht da
schaue ich gleich mal ganz spontan
vorbei trinkt einen kaffee oder so es
sonst kuchen was weiß ich deute ich
würde sagen wir schauen uns mal kurz die
rezension an dann muss ich auch noch
kurz was dort zu sagen also hier kann
man zehn 1,3 sterne
wir haben auch nur vier rezensionen aber
davon ist halt keine positiv deswegen
das fand ich schon grasbahn heute zu
zweit bei der bäckerei im all so ist
halt so ein kaufhaus wo das drin ist
anscheinend von kundenorientierten
verhalten gibt es keine spur weder
augenkontakt eine richtige begrüßung und
generell ein freundliches auftreten
konnte uns entgegengebracht werden
abgesehen davon dass diese mit mehreren
verkäufern stehen schaffen diese nicht
einen kunden aus der reihe zu bedienen
sondern komplett falsche reihenfolge
will am liebsten keinen stern geben
ziemlich enttäuschend ok ich stand
geschlagene sechs minuten an der theke
und viele verkäufer und standen
gemeinsam an der kasse nachdem ich die
frage dauert es noch länger gestellt
habe bekam ich die antwort wir müssen
erst etwas in der kasse eingeben das
kann
auf eine von ihnen übernehmen sonst bin
ich das kann auch eine von ihnen
übernehmen sonst bin ich weg und gehen
woanders hin wo ein kundenorientierter
hier bei dieser schlechten kehm tolle
aschenbecher auf der lebensmittel theke
ist nicht in ordnung
ich habs jetzt schon in letzter zeit
gelernt dass manche rezension auch
wirklich sehr hart sind ja und leute
jetzt kommt das steht ja auch noch
darunter
bild wurde anscheinend in einer filiale
geschossen würde fernbleiben und wenn
man sich dieses bild anguckt masse und
es scheint ja dann also mehrere filialen
davon zu geben und wird halt
wahrscheinlich nicht in dieser ihr
gemacht keine ahnung vorsichtig wir
haben auf jeden fall so mäuse die die
theke stürmen
also sind dann immer so sachen die ich
meine wir hatten es schon bei dem
supermarkt im internet kann jeder
schreiben was er will deswegen ja ich
kann mir so was aber nur so richtig
schwer vorstellen was ich jetzt noch
dazu sagen wollte also es ist ja ganz
klar dass man jetzt nicht in jedem lokal
absolut was dreckiges findet dass die
bedienung und freundlich ist dass das
essen nicht schmeckt also in diesem fall
halt jetzt eine bäckerei die muss in
köln vernünftige ware haben weil sonst
halt einfach nicht überleben also es
kann jetzt nicht sein dass wir hier
irgendwo eine bäckerei haben die
komplett eklige ware verkauft
da gehe ich nicht von aus sondern so
etwas fällt dann halt immer auf die
mitarbeiter zurück und in diesem fall
kann man so ein laden dann denke ich mal
nur auf die mitarbeiter und vielleicht
auch auf die sauberkeit
ich will jetzt nicht sagen dass das
video eher langweilig wird heute wir
schauen natürlich trotzdem vorbei haben
wir viele von euch sich gewünscht und
ich bin einfach mal gespannt was auf
mich zukommt dann würde ich sagen wir
laden gar nicht lange gibt auf jeden
fall noch nach oben für weitere pass und
schreibt ideen für weitere partner in
die kommentare wir sind schon auf die
block m und will ganz gleich so leicht
würde ich sagen wir mal raus auf den weg
ich bin gespannt wie es hier eine sachen
auch und zwar steht was richtig cool ist
an am nächsten mit braucht deswegen volk
mit da gerne sehr sehr wichtig deswegen
folgt mir doch bitte auf instagram 30
alex w
dann verpasst du das nicht und ich hoffe
dass meine story ich kann euch
versprechen das wird cool da gibt es
auch wieder zu aber wenn ihr aktuell
sein wollt da steckt auf jeden fall den
installateur markt so da bin ich gegen
die mauer gefahren und jetzt fahren wir
acht kilometer um zu einer bäckerei zu
kommen sollen wir nachdenken es bestimmt
weltrekord ich meine wer etwa acht
kilometer bis zur bäckerei gefahren
bäckereien gibt es ja sonst überall so
leute ich bin angekommen das ding ist
also ich sehe schon genau davor und
deswegen würden wir jetzt auf das handy
ich mache das ja immer am liebsten weil
ja mit handy film ist ganz normal und
wir schauen mal wie das darin appelliert
aber an sich sieht erstmal relativ
normal aus also bis gleich
ich habe gerne unseren cappuccino normal
[Musik]
also leute ich würde mal sagen kann man
sich auf jeden fall nicht darüber
beschweren
die nutzer schmeckt wirklich sehr lecker
habe ich früher ganz gerne mal gegessen
von der kampf okay ich sitz hier nicht
in der sonne
aber ich glaube ich gebe euch trotzdem
mal eine schlechte bewertung habe
einfach so dann stellt sich heraus ob
die kamera das hält oder nicht was ich
gut ausleuchtet also habt mitgekriegt
ich war in der schlechtesten begleiten
ich muss das mal sagen das ist immer so
schade wenn so einen laden eigentlich um
eine schlechte bewertung hat aber es
waren sich eine stinknormale bäckerei
mit freundlicher bedienung habt ja
selber gesehen also ich geb dir gleich
einfach mal fünf sterne weil dann hat
das ding auch gleich mal ein besseres
internet auftreten sage ich mal so weil
wie gesagt ich frage mich immer sind
diese leute ja ist dann so schlecht
bewerten wirklich so spießig oder so
kritisch man muss dazu sagen die
schlange da war schon relativ lang und
die bedienung war freundlich also es war
jetzt nicht so dass er halt nix los war
und man dann diese unfreundlichkeit
damit begründen kann ok das war so viel
los und bei dir war jetzt gar nichts los
wenn ihr jetzt versteht was ich meine
ach so leute ganz kurz noch da waren ja
auch so tiere eben in den rezensionen
das ist so halt so richtig krass
rufschädigung aber in der filiale
bessert sich so natürlich habe man ach
da gibt es auch mehrere filialen von
sogar soweit ich weiß in ganz
deutschland ja ich weiss nicht also kann
ich noch mal sagen schöne bäckerei kann
man mal lecker und brötchen kaufen ja
das sind dann halt irgendwie so tests
an sich muss man ja ganz ehrlich sagen
das video jetzt dass er langweilig gebe
ich noch offen und ehrlich zu so also es
gibt spannendere tests von mir was guckt
hinter mir so das sind auch mal die
besten die gucken so richtig so hält
kamera genau also sagen wir mal so es
gibt deutlich spannendere trainiert
trotzdem muss ich dann auch fairerweise
sagen also also es wäre jetzt auch
irgendwie komisch wenn ich das ganze
nicht hochladen würde weil ich habe die
schlechteste becker heraus gesucht und
diese getestet und das ergebnis war
komplett anders als es im internet steht
weil sonst alles schlecht bewertet leben
die ich getestet habe die waren auch
wirklich schlecht so in köln ist das
manchmal so krass mit so obdachlosen die
dann tut mir sehr leid aber kann man
auch nichts machen ich würde sagen dass
war es wird im video schreibt wie gesagt
weiteres fest in die kommentare beim
nächsten mal wird es bestimmt wieder ein
bisschen interessanter ich hoffe ihr
seid mir nicht böse dass das heute keine
grusel bäckerei war mit verstümmelten
brot und ja wir sehen uns auf jeden fall
mein instagram account ab ich freue mich
so auf das wird echt von einem cool und
ich nehme euch dort mit also macht das
und hoffe ein abo nicht vergessen